cuando la asamblea nacional francesa
voto a favor de la abolición de la pena
de muerte hace 40 años más del 60% de la
población seguía apoyando la pena
capital pero luego el presidente
françois mitterrand mantuvo su promesa
de campaña sin importar el costo
político
estoy en contra de la pena de muerte no
necesito leer encuestas de opinión que
digan lo contrario y listo contra él
el hombre que impulsó el proyecto de ley
que abolía las ejecuciones fue uno de
los abogados más notorios de francia que
fue después ministro de justicia joven
bad antes un hombre que ya no soportaba
una decapitación más incluida la de su
propio cliente joya montón ejecutado por
complicidad en un robo a mano armada
y que montan fue ejecutado eso significa
cortar a un hombre vivo en dos dedos
juré que no me opondría solo a la pena
de muerte se convertiría en activista
quienes defendían las ejecuciones
dijeron que disuadían a las personas de
cometer delitos violentos van antes dijo
que este no era el caso
su propio cliente el asesino de niños
convicto patrick hoy y siempre había
apoyado la pena capital el 18 de
septiembre de 1981 la asamblea nacional
aprobó la ley con 363 votos a favor y
117 en contra
40 años después los franceses siguen
divididos con sondeos de opinión que
muestran que aproximadamente la mitad de
los encuestados se oponen a la pena
capital mientras que la otra mitad dice
que debería restablecerse